for Black History Month we are
celebrating trailblazers who became
leaders in their field that helped to
change the course of history and this
morning two athletes from different
generations who helped reshape their
sport Willie O'Ree broke the NHL's color
barrier back in 1958 the Boston Bruins
winger took the ice in the midst of
America's tumultuous fight to end Jim
Crow Oh Rican a daeun is now 84 years
old 27 year old and the zynga Prescott
is an African foil fencer Americans are
a foil fencer in 2015 she became the
first African American woman to win an
individual medal at the World
Championships these two Trailblazers met
for the very first time recently in
Washington DC where they talked about
their historic journeys and the work
that still needs to be done when I
stepped on the ice I didn't realize that
I was breaking the color barrier or
opening doors and I read it in the paper
the next day for me and my sport and
fencing I've been won a few but I can't
imagine what it's like to be the the
only person that looks like you so how
did it make you feel I was thrilled you
know to be on the team and at that time
and I was faced with some from racism
but I just kept it in my mind that I'm
here to be the best hockey player I can
be and to represent the hockey club to
the best of my ability I feel like it's
kind of an extra feat that you have to
overcome I don't feel I know that I
started fencing to the Peter Ostrow
foundation in New York
Peter the sixth time Olympian he's
African American and he wanted to bring
fencing to more minority youth in New
York and so while he started this
program and he sponsored my training
because fencing is super expensive so it
excludes a lot of the population I think
we spent like seven or eight fencers to
the Olympics and so I had this community
of black fencers that made it really fun
and exciting but I don't know what it
would have been like does not have that
buffer the name-calling in the racial
remarks we were there I've had cotton
balls thrown on the outside and black
cats throwing on the ice you know in
different cities and but I always kept
it on the ice I have one thought
mind to play hockey and beat the best
hockey player right to this day
systematically even if it's not by
saying you're black you're not allowed I
think there's other constructs that have
been developed to exclude black people
and I think it's wrong that you can only
access certain sports if you have a
certain amount of money do you think
Jackie Robinson impacted your decision
to stay in sport yes he did he made a
big impact well I met Jackie Robinson on
two occasions I met him when I was 14
went down to the dugout shook hands with
him and I told mr. Robinson that I not
only played baseball but I played hockey
and he didn't realize that there were
any black kids playing hockey in 1962
the n-double-a-cp had a luncheon for mr.
Robinson and mr. Robinson turned and he
says he remembered from 1949 to 1962 and
I was at all but he did it was so
important he knew how important it was
yeah and because he'd done it and now
I'm called the Jackie Robinson of hockey
or to the media gave me that name
I don't feel like a trailblazer I just
feel like a but you are an individual
that that excelled in the game that he
loved and to be the first and anything
is this is great yeah I want to show you
I got this Friday in the mail
oh wow the Canadian Mint has made a $20
silver on the other side is the Queen on
some money it's really respectful what
you're doing with the NHL to change that
like structure in the sports world here
finish playing my career I wanted to
give back to the Boras to control the
puck and then when I came with the NHL
and worked with the diversity program
helping kids play hockey and learning
how to skate and ride they're doing it
now for 20 going on 23 years and it's
just second love I'm with you I want to
share my sport I don't want anyone to
feel any one of many
[Music]
Wow what a lovely conversation between
the two of them and I think that they
would each feed each other yeah it was
really beautiful to see who did that
guys that was really nicely done
well done Mike that was very very nice
little hint of what Willie went through
in 1958 coming up in the NHL yeah might
say thank you that was really really
beautiful you know what I like I like
when she said but you are a trailblazers
and I like no question he was and I love
the Jackie Robinson remembered him
that's how unusual he was yes that he
still on skates at 84 Wow nice